on reste au bord de l'eau avec une
tradition de la région d'antil bénis et
jusqu'à menton autorisé 45 jours
seulement par an il s'agit de la pêche à
la poutine une sorte de friture que l'on
peut également consommer cru et qui est
menacée dit-on par les fonctionnaires de
Bruxelles ce qui ne plaît pas du tout
aux pêcheurs de la région Yasmina
farbert Didier be au petit matin les
pêcheurs partent de la plage d'entibe à
la recherche d'un trésor transparent et
argenté la poutine pour cette pêche un
filet de 80 m et largué tout près du
rivage une véritable moustiquaire où
viendront se perdre les alvins d'anchois
et de sardines la tradition remonte à
Napoléon I de Menton à Antibe les
pêcheurs répètent les gestes de leurs
ancêtres selon l'état de la mer ils
ramèneront quelques kilos de ce précieux
magot une pêche originale qu'ils
n'abandonneront à aucun prix avec les
lois européennes il
voudrait réglementer toutes ces pêches
qui qui sortent un peu de l'ordinaire
mais moi je dis que pour la tradition il
faut quand même le garder c'est c'est
c'est vraiment quelque chose du pays ni
soit pays antibois il y a que nous qu'on
le pratique queles que soient les
conditions météo la pêche à la poutine
ne dure que 45 jours et un pêcheur ne
rechigne jamais à goûter son caviè du
Sud dès sa sortie de la
Méditerranée tu à quelle goû
noisette de la noisette de la noisette
c'est vrai c'est bon avec un petit fond
de moule
cette saveur se vend bien 1 heure à
peine après la pêche la poutine se
retrouve au marché d'entibe environ 20
francs les 100 g plus si elle s'est
faite plus rare il ne reste plus qu'à la
cuisiner surtout sans tuer le goût
chacun a sa recette
fétiche mon goût c'est l'omelette on la
prépare juste avec un petit peu d'ail et
de persil à peine à peine pour la
relever avec un peu d'huile on l' fait
saisir et pu on la tourne il faut
qu'elle soit baveuse c'est comme ça
qu'elle est bonne très bonne aussi
pochée enbeigné ou cru avec un jus de
citron pour les puristes une gourmandise
de quelques semaines après ce sera le
retour de la petite
friture